I believe that the first principle of
conservatism is that truth matters you
know my truth matters truth matters
because you have value as an individual
and when I lie to you I am devaluing you
as a human being
taking lies as part of politics is not
acceptable suggesting that lying is okay
so long as it's someone on your side
that is not acceptable you're valuing
people who have to make a free decision
on the basis of information they are
given you cannot do that and see
yourself as a decent human being
lies are not acceptable in politics just
because it's politics just because
everybody else is cynical doesn't mean
you have to be and just because that
cynicism sometimes results in victory
doesn't mean it results in ultimate
victory because ultimately when you
promise people things they can't deliver
when you promise people things that are
not delivered you end up undermining
your own credibility standing out to the
side saying look truth matters truth
always matters
and if that means that sometimes we lose
that means sometimes we lose in the end
the only things worth winning are the
things that are based on truth and I
know there's this mentality that now
dominates among a certain segments of
Republicans that says okay well if we
have to lie here here and here in order
to get the bigger truth conservatism
through that'll be okay that's not how
it works if you have to lie here here
and here in order to get conservatism
through if you have to pretend to be a
Democrat on nine issues in order to get
that big tenth one through all you're
gonna end up with is those nine issues
being debunked and your eventual tenth
victory is gonna be torn away there's
what Barack Obama found out on the left
you lied about Obama care a thousand
times you know Obama care is on the
ropes and it should be and right now for
publicans lie about what they're gonna
replace it with they're gonna be on the
ropes two lies do not pay off